[Music]
Hey kid hey kiss me Kevin Smith and
guess what we're at that place I never
wanted to be what is that you ask
[ __ ] a place of dignity or something
like that no talking about the end of
the convenience tour man clerks 3 the
convenience tour came to a conclusion
tonight here in Hartford Connecticut and
it was incredibly Bittersweet I never
wanted this [ __ ] to end man I'll be
honest with you I've said it before I'll
say it again every night it's like going
to a church with a congregation thinks
you're both the priest and Jesus why
would you ever want to leave that behind
this was a dream that I had since we
were on the Jay and Silent Bob reboot
Road Show tour you know and that was
like selling out everywhere and
audiences were so lovely and interactive
I was like oh my God imagine if I came
back with a good movie and that's what
clerks 3 is and was a good movie a good
movie to stand behind uh 52 shows
um intro the movie watch the movie with
you all and then sat there afterwards
and talked about it for longer length
than the movie itself oftentimes
that was the dream I had for the clerk's
three convenience tour and here we are
man dream comes to a close
um torn because of naturally I'd like it
to keep going I tried to add more dates
I told Jordan man just please just a few
more dates but she's like you gotta stop
you gotta like it's time to start the
next thing we're at the end of the
[ __ ] year and stuff you've been doing
this for a quarter of the Year touring
the movie gotta get back to life and so
that's what we're gonna do get back to
life but what did it look like what was
what what am I going to miss why am I so
sad that the tour is ending well
how about I show you
uh [ __ ] kids I'm gonna milk this because
I only get to do this one last time for
the rest of my [ __ ] life
[Applause]
and it's going to be very hard to say
[ __ ] I'm not wearing the right sneakers
Liv can you go grab my sneakers
I'm doing it wrong if we're gonna do it
right we gotta do a [ __ ] right those
are my outdoor sneakers and [ __ ] I have
performance sneakers
while we kill time you'll notice my
painted toenails my friends
that's because I'm very sexual
uh the lady said your toenails look so
[ __ ] bad I was like paint them quick
quick thank you
very much don't get up get up
thank you all right it's official we're
doing a show I got my clerk sneakers on
there's a uh a wonderful fan out in Los
Angeles her name is one crafty Punk on
Instagram and she came up to me after a
show one day I was coming out of comic
book store and she goes your sneakers
are so [ __ ] ugly take these
and she made me [ __ ] clerk sneakers
and I'm like [ __ ] life should be like
that all the time
um yeah it's gonna be really hard to let
this one go it wasn't very difficult to
let the reboot Roadshow tour end uh 65
cities and and half of them I did with
Jay and the other half I did by myself I
was never by myself just like on this
tour I was never by myself I've always
had live and Josh as well but when it
came time for the reboot Roadshow toward
and it was very easy uh to let go so for
the last time ever before I die
it's true I never get to do this again
man I only get one [ __ ] shot at the
52nd show [ __ ] you I'm gonna milk it
no I don't want to stand
but you're right you paid for a show
let's put on a [ __ ] show uh ladies
and gentlemen welcome to the Hartford
stop of Clerks three the convenience
tour
we've been dreading this for a while
kids because this meant the end of it
this is our final show I mean we were
always like wow what's going to be like
at the end and it's sad it's bittersweet
I hate to see it end but I couldn't
think of a better group of people to end
it all with so under your chair you will
find cyanide we will all
we're all going out
all right kids we shall dive into some q
a man we got microphone just one
microphone that's it and there's another
one so there's a mic there there's a mic
there uh whoever gets up and starts the
Q a bam the world is yours look at you
that was fast
what's your name Captain George George
everyone giving up for George he's going
first
leave it up with the guy with the panic
attack disorder to be the first one to
come up here and get it done do you get
panic attacks right well I'm having one
right now hold my hand this will make it
easier
we can do this George
we got this
if I can get a little more rope hold on
here ask the question I'll be a human
mic stand I'll hold your one hand and
Mike stand the other
[Applause]
this isn't too awkward is it George
[Applause]
sorry
I have a new fan I uh learned about you
from my husband who's like your number
one fan I'm pretty sure he passed he
passed this on like herpes to you
we love that that's how our [ __ ] catches
on man other people go like oh you got
to watch this the people who are into
this stuff are so into it they pass it
on with passion to somebody else and and
that's how my careers Thrive for over a
quarter of a century
um
I will let her ask the [ __ ] question
well
just my night my last
are you are you the same guy who's
saying he's milking it
that was hysterical
um I'll remember this night for the rest
of my life man uh this is where it all
ended this is three four years of like
dreaming you know manifesting a dream is
it's like [ __ ] you know it's it's
nearly impossible if everybody could do
it we'd all do it constantly and [ __ ]
like that making it happen takes a lot
of effort and a lot of work and a lot of
[ __ ] talent and we did it and then we
got to take it out into the world and I
was always dreading this [ __ ] moment
because this is the end I never get to
do this with this movie again there'll
be variations there'll be other tours
there'll be other movies but the
convenience tour will only end [ __ ]
once and I was dreading this moment for
the last three months but you people
made it so [ __ ] wonderful that I got
to let go man
thank you Hartford
Hartford ladies and gentlemen and give
it up for the one the only Dante Hicks
Brian o'hower and ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
Hartford I'm Gonna Leave You with the
same thought that Becky says in the
movie Man Live While You Can Love while
you can and God damn it Connecticut
dream bigger I love you all good night
[Applause]
without these two right here it's lovely
[ __ ] married couple who had me pull
their pingle in the [ __ ] cut all the
time these kids right here made the
convenience tour man made it happen
every night uh we drove uh you know for
hours sometimes and we'd get to a place
at night and he would make sure the
movie played never had a technical
glitch
not once the entire time when he says
they mean Kevin 70 of the time Josh 30
of the time me 0.1 percent of the time
oh Liv drove she drove us all crazy
um
I listened to Manhattan one morning at
4am and got lost and added 20 minutes we
won't talk about that yeah we were
sleeping in the car and woke up like
where are we this is Queens
I took a turn
um he made [ __ ] happen she made [ __ ]
happen all the time if you uh met me on
tour uh through that Kevin Smith club or
whatnot this is how it happened uh these
two kids took care of me throughout this
entire experience just like they did on
Jay and Silent Bob reboot Roadshow tour
um and part of the like when I was like
oh I can't wait to go back out on tour
uh it was with the movie it was to see
the audience but I knew I got to hang
out with these kids the whole time we
drove for hours we sang we [ __ ]
bonded and [ __ ] like that we dreamed we
hatched schemes and [ __ ] all the things
that you see do you ever see Almost
Famous when they go on the road and [ __ ]
like a band that's what we are we're
like a band and Liz figured it out tell
them what we are as a band Kevin's the
lead singer obviously Josh is the
drummer because you can't do a show
without him the movies the lead
guitarist because it takes all the
attention and I'm the replaceable
bassist I'm sorry you left out one term
the replaceable female bases
um the the our little band is now going
to jump off tour for a minute man I've
been out there talking for the last
quarter of the of the year and uh I I'm
gonna go show a movie with these kids
they made their movie wrong reasons
which tonight we're from tonight because
it's midnight here we're gonna be in Los
Angeles showing it and stuff and then
after that that's it I'm not gonna talk
again for the rest of the Never Never
saying a [ __ ] word no
um done talking unless you go to Spa
Castle and I talk all the time and stuff
uh thanks everybody and thank you kids
for making this all happen man yeah I
love you too I love you too I I honestly
I would I want to cry but I don't
because I don't want the internet to
yell at me ever again so tired of that
uh there it is
the clerk's three convenience tour kids
in the books it's done it's a thing that
happened you can't [ __ ] stop it uh
and it happened because all three of
these people you're looking at right
here plus a bunch of people even aren't
here Jordan Monsanto made this tour
happen
Chelsea made this tour happen Luke and
and uh all my all the merch that got
sent to Rissa Mike zapsick Carol
um uh oh Seth Siegel at WME he booked
all these events for us
don't you don't have to you have to quit
[Laughter]
we've quit [ __ ] off yeah we're done man
shirts off and [ __ ]
kids
thank you for hanging out yeah I got
very strange I thank God we didn't lose
one more layer of peace be [ __ ]
horrible uh thank you everybody for
making my dreams come true man
foreign
[Music]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]